- Dans toute cette saga,
Hockey Canada a réussi
un exploit rare : faire
l'unanimité au Parlement.
L'opinion est partagée par tous
les partis. Andrea Skinner doit
être le premier domino à tomber,
disent-ils.
RICHARD MARTEL, député, PCC,
ancien entraîneur de hockey
- Tant que les gens sont
en place, moi, je ne vois pas
la lumière au bout du tunnel.
- Devant le Comité du patrimoine
en début de semaine, Mme Skinner
avait défendu bec et ongles
son organisation. Le lendemain,
Hockey Québec désavouait
la fédération nationale.
Ça a été l'élément déclencheur,
selon ce député
du Bloc québécois.
SÉBASTIEN LEMIRE, porte-pa
Bloc québ. en matière de Sport
- Elle a agi comme étant
le bras exécutif de la haute
direction et c'est ça
qui est problématique.
Quand elQuand elQuand elQuand ee
du travail de Scott Smith
et qu'elle dit que la faute
est aux autres, bien forcément,
elle n'a pas joué son rôleet c',
qu'elle a quitté.
- Les élus réclament davantage
de changements. Déjà, cinq des
neuf membres du C.A. ne seront
pas de retour après l'assemblée
générale du mois de décembre.
Deux d'entre eux écoulent
leur dernier mandat;
un autre ne se représentera pas;
tandis que Michael Brind'Amour
et Andrea Skinner ont
démissionné.
À l'unisson, les parlementaires
demandent aussi la tête du
directeur général Scott Smith.
- C'est le grand ménage qui doit
être opéré par Hockey Canada.
Actuellement, on est encore dans
une opération de camouflage.
Mme Skinner passe pour
une bouc émissaire dans
les circ Ce n'est pas
à elle de payer pour l'ensemble
des choses qu'on reproche
actuellement à Hockey Canada.
- Au coeur du problème :
la structure de gouvernance.
Un ancien juge de la Cour
suprême doit remettre
un rapport à ce sujet dans
les prochaines semaines.
Il ne s'agit pas seulement
de faire table rase du C.A.,
mais d'identifier le profil
des gens qui devraient y siéger.
- Je pense que s'il y a
des nouvelles personnes
estructuration,
la confiance va revenir peu
à peu, les commanditaires
vont revenir, et on va pouvoir
aller de l'avant.
- De son côté, Hockey Québec
n'a pas souhaité commenter
ce dernier rebondissement.
dent du C.A.,
Claude Fortin, s'est contenté
de dire qu'il "allait laisser
Hockey Canada gérer sa crise."
Ici Alexandre Gascon,
Radio-Canada, à